let me see our look glasses no blood no
glass Gigi style suck is yz4 one and
this is on the rocks
I'm up so using my ice young jeezy gave
me a Rolex with a red face back in the
day scene just like why do you need some
dream like nah I'm not incident you he
can't press me you know I never got
nothing he's just buzzing one like as a
rap artist people expecting this you
know I'm Julian I probably think I got
my jury because the homie got jury I'd
be tired of [ __ ] talking about
watching some dreary sergeants guys on
like DJ mustard like the [ __ ] got all
the type of Germany [ __ ] but he always
taught my kid some jurors I finally got
some but like the jury thing ain't my
really denominated my swag like I got a
whole bunch of fun to change I got all
type of other [ __ ] I got a lot of [ __ ]
that I don't even wear just sitting it's
a bus down a jeweler forgot his name
I barely wear it like it ain't classy to
be like it won't match my outfits and
[ __ ] like the all-gold like the plain
jangling is the one of the hallways
weird but I left it got about the crib
Photoshop me kidding me Plus down to the
wings a custom Chuck bracelet with the
red chucks on it I got this in New York
I'm tatted on me with red laces in
this reflection on a wife come from and
then these little braces wasn't gift the
homegirl she went on set when I was
shooting the white boy Rick movie that
just came out and she told me mom said
she was gonna gift me with some cherry
and all that and all she brought it to
the premiere what's this [ __ ] car right
here right they like posted Patek he was
something if they breaking me some bad
[ __ ] was happening but like the birds
had stopped it or something
she necklaces too low white diamonds on
one of them all roads go with the red
rubies like I wear to over it three of
them now they heavy is [ __ ]
here's another [ __ ] mustard I mean
this has a gift for Christmas say full
hundred summers four hundred is my brand
and label ten summers is mustard but we
came with together new homies and all
that we like a brother company when we
do our thing together we fall under
summer I'm gonna get a buzz down Cuban
link below I got to do like the G [ __ ]
like bridges look gangster [ __ ] back in
the deck roll excuse me [ __ ] rollers
ring its cousin I [ __ ] with the Rings
yeah and then if you fighting machine
somebody in the face and you got on
rings it's bad like brass knuckles or
something you know like blow bar fights
and [ __ ]
protect yourself I think the amigos be
going crazy
hello yah TPP went crazy rocky got some
new [ __ ] he got like something first
into your or some custom special [ __ ]
brach came in a gang with a big eyes
watchin something I had a bigger thing I
just feel like that [ __ ] don't fit with
our hobby swagging and I come out the
house as my style change so do some of
the things I wear jury ain't a big part
of it is more like small little things
like my white socks with the hora bottom
or some shorts and I'm saying like Van
Dyne and [ __ ] like that I'd rather play
with that type of [ __ ] jury do some
picture add-on for me but I'm gonna
barge everything you know I'm about
typical rapper [ __ ] [ __ ] by jury
[ __ ] body dump [ __ ] by the Lambos and
[ __ ] like that be doing all that oh you
see what I got in my jury bag a whole
bunch of bandanas bro I got the louis
vuitton red bandana like i meant to [ __ ]
like this it's the best piece of jury
uhm nothing
oh man i'm bad man I gotta be a better
frame